"THE STORY" GOES ON TOMORROW
NIGHT, SEE YOU THEN.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT"
TONIGHT.
LOOKING BACK JANUARY OF 2017, IT
SEEMS LIKE ANOTHER AGE.
SO MUCH HAS HAPPENED IN THE YEAR
SINCE THEN, BUT IN OTHER WAYS
NOT THAT MUCH HAS CHANGED AT
ALL.
DONALD TRUMP AND NOT EVEN TAKEN
THE OATH OF OFFICE YET, BUT BY
THE FIRST WEEK OF THE NEW YEAR
OF 2017, I GUESS DON'T REMEMBER,
HE HAD ALREADY COMMITTED TO
DESTROYING HIS PRESIDENCY AND
TRUMP SEEM TO KNOW IT.
A LITTLE AFTER 8:00 P.M. ON THE
NIGHT OF JANUARY 3RD 2017 THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT WROTE A TWEET,
HE TOOK A VEILED DIG AT U.S.
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND THEIR
HANDLING OF THE NEWLY INITIATED
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME MOMENT,
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AR
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AV
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AN
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AG
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AA
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AT
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AM
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AN
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AC
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AS
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AM
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AD
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AO
CHUCK SCHUMER OF NEW YORK WAS AN
MANHATTAN STUDIO'S.
HE WENT TO THE SET AND THE
ANCHOR OF THE SHOW HE WAS ON
THAT NIGHT, RACHEL MADDOW HOLD
UP HIS TWEET ON A SCREEN, LIVE
ON TV AND ASKED CHUCK SCHUMER TO
COMMENT ON THAT.
HE ENDS IN THE WEEK BEFORE AND
HE COULDN'T HAVE KNOWN IT WAS
COMING, FOR ONE OF THE MORE
CALCULATING POLITICIANS IN
WASHINGTON, IT WAS A RARE
UNSCRIPTED MOMENT.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME CHUCK SCHUMER WENT WITH THE
UNVARNISHED TRUTH.
WATCH WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU TAKE ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THEN SIX WAYS FROM
SUNDAY OF GETTING BACK AT YOU.
EVEN FOR PRACTICAL, SUPPOSEDLY
HARD-NOSED BUSINESSMAN HE IS
BEING REALLY DUMB TO DO THIS.
>> Tucker: CHUCK SCHUMER WENT
ON TO SAY HE DIDN'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE SPY AGENCIES WERE DUE A
DONALD TRUMP AS PUNISHMENT FOR
BEING DUMB ENOUGH TO CRITICIZE
THEM IN PUBLIC, BUT HE WARNED
AND THIS IS VERBATIM QUOTE, FROM
WHAT I AM TOLD THEY ARE VERY
UPSET ABOUT HOW HE HAS TREATED
THEM AND TALKED ABOUT THEM.
VERY UPSET.
GOT IT?
THERE IS NO MISTAKING WHAT THAT
WAS.
THAT'S A THREAT ISSUED ON LIVE
TELEVISION WITH GRAVE
SERIOUSNESS BY A POLITICIAN WHO
HAS BEEN IN WASHINGTON LONG
ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY REAL.
IN THE END DONALD TRUMP IGNORED
IT, OR MORE LIKELY HE DECIDED TO
DEFY IT.
DAY AFTER DAY HE GAVE THE FINGER
TO THE PERMANENT WASHINGTON
ESTABLISHMENT COME ON AND OFF
TWITTER, SOMETIMES AT PRESS
CONFERENCES, BUT ALWAYS WITH
UNMISTAKABLE RELISH.
HE ACTED LIKE A MAN WHO HAD WON
IN ELECTION IN A DEMOCRATIC
COUNTRY AND HE SEEMED TO FEEL
FREE TO SAY EXACTLY WHAT HE
THOUGHT.
HE DIDN'T APPEAR TO BELIEVE THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES HAD VETO
POWER OVER HIS AGENDA.
IN A THOUSAND DIFFERENT WAYS THE
NEW PRESIDENT REFUSED TO BOW AND
FOR THAT CRIME MORE THAN ANY
OTHER CRIME, HE WAS PUNISHED.
MOST RECENTLY BY THE
MANUFACTURER IN UKRAINE SCANDAL.
THE INTEL WORLD HAS BECOME
DEFIANT, JUST YESTERDAY AT THE
FORMER CEI DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN
EXPRESSED OUTRAGE THAT ANYONE
WOULD EVER DARE OVERSIGHT THAT
SECRETLY OVERSEE OUR LIVES.
>> I'M SUPPOSEDLY GOING TO BE
INTERVIEWED BY MR. DURHAM AS
THERE IS NO INVESTIGATION.
WILLIAM BARR WHEN HE WAS
TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
AT A DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
PREDICATION OF THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS LAUNCHED
INTO RUSSIAN'S INTERFERENCE IN
THE 2016 ELECTION.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
PREDICATION OF THIS WORLDWIDE
EFFORT TO TRY AND COVER DIRT,
EITHER REAL OR IMAGINED THAT WE
DISCREDIT THAT INVESTIGATION IN
2016 AND THE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE.
>> Tucker: JOHN BRENNAN IS A
NAKED PARTISAN AND HE IS A LIAR.
HE HAS ACTED IN WAYS THAT WOULD
HAVE SHOCKED AND HORRIFIED
PREVIOUS DIRECTOR IS NOT SAYING
A LOT.
JOHN BRENNAN IS NOT ASHAMED, FAR
FROM WHAT HE IS PROUD AND SO ARE
AS MANY ACCOLADES IN WASHINGTON.
PHILMONT IS A FORMER CIA
EMPLOYEE LIKE SO MANY PARTISANS
FROM INTELLIGENCE WORLD HE
IS NO CONTRIBUTOR AT CNN.
LAST NIGHT HE SENT AN ON AIR
WARNING TO THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
LAWYER, BACK OFF OR PREPARED TO
GET HURT.
>> I SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN
GOVERNMENT.
THERE ARE STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS WILL TESTIFY COME AND
TELL GUYS, DEPARTMENT,
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE PEOPLE
COME ALL OF US ARE A BROTHERHOOD
AND SISTERHOOD.
RUDY GIULIANI PARACHUTES AND
FROM MARS.
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL TESTIFY ARE
GOING TO LOOK AT HIM INCLUDING
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS AND
SAY, I DON'T HAVE TO PROTECT
THAT GUY.
HE DIDN'T OPERATE BY THE RULES.
HE DIDN'T DO WHAT YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO IN GOVERNMENT.
I SUSPECT HE IS WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT THE CONGRESS WILL DO.
IF I WERE HIM I WOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT THE PEOPLE AND
GOVERNMENT STICK A SHIV IN HIS
BACK.
HE'S IN TROUBLE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A BROTHERHOOD
SAYS PHIL, THE CIA, A
BROTHERHOOD THAT WILL STAB YOU
TO DEATH IF YOU DISOBEY.
WHAT HE IS DESCRIBING IS NOT A
CONVENTIONAL GOVERNMENT AGENCY,
NOTHING LIKE WHAT MOST OF US
IMAGINE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
WASHINGTON IS DOING ON OUR
BEHALF.
THE CA OF JOHN BRENNAN AND PHIL
MUDD DOES NOT EXIST FOR OUR
BENEFIT, AND EXIST FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
THERE.
WE PAY FOR THE WHOLE THING, BUT
THEY DO WHAT THEY WANT AND THEY
PUNISH ANYONE WHO CRITICIZES
THEM.
THEY BRAG ABOUT THAT.
NOW THAT IS SCARY, A PERVERSION
OF DEMOCRACY AND WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO CREATED THE CIA FEARED MOST.
IT'S ALSO -- IF OR WHEN TO BE
HONEST, IT'S ANNOYING BECAUSE
FOR ALL OF THE HYPE, THE
CIA AND THE END ISN'T EVEN VERY
GOOD AT ITS JOB.
REMEMBER, THIS IS AN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY!
IT'S FAIR TO JUDGE THEIR
PERFORMANCE AGAINST WHETHER OR
NOT THEY PREDICTED CRUCIAL
EVENTS OVER THE PAST 70 YEARS.
AGAIN AND AGAIN, THEY DIDN'T.
THE CIA FOR EXAMPLE WAS SHOCKED
BY THE KOREAN WAR.
THEY DIDN'T PREDICT THE SOVIET
ATOMIC BOMB, NOT A SMALL THING.
THEY MISSED THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS AND THE ISRAELI WAR, THEY
SPENT DECADES TRYING TO BRING
DOWN FIDEL CASTRO -- TO KILL
FIDEL CASTRO, SO NATURALLY HAS A
RESUME EVER FELT.
HE LIVED INTO HIS 90s.
THE CIA SPENT DECADES PROPPING
UP THE SHELL OF IRAN SO
NATURALLY HE TUMBLED FROM POWER.
THEY DID PROVIDE A WARNING
BEFORE BECAUSE HE HAD NO IDEA.
WHEN THE IRON CURTAIN FINALLY
FELL IN 1989 THE CI WAS
COMPLETELY BLINDSIDED BY IT,
THEY THOUGHT THEY PREDICTED IN
FACT THE SOVIET UNION WASN'T
STRONG AS EVER.
THINGS DIDN'T GET BETTER AFTER
THAT.
THE CIA HAD NO IDEA THAT SADDAM
HUSSEIN PLANNED TO EVADE THE WAY
THE NEXT YEAR, THEY WERE
SURPRISED BY INDIA'S ATOMIC BOMB
TEST EIGHT YEARS LATER.
BUT 2003 THEY WERE TOTALLY
CONFIDENT THAT IRAQ HAD WEAPONS
OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
IN FACT, TO BIGGEST SUCCESS
MIGHT'VE BEEN CRATING THE
TALIBAN.
IF JOHN BRENNAN HAD BEEN WORKING
FOR A NONPROFIT BUSINESS THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN A SHAREHOLDER
REVOLT A LONG TIME AGO AND
PROBABLY CRIMINAL CHARGES.
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN JOHN
DeLOREAN.
BECAUSE IT'S A SECRETIVE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY, THE CA HAS
NOT BEEN RESTRAINED, IN FACT
IT'S ONLY BECOME MORE POWERFUL
AND MORE AUTONOMOUS SPIRIT
POWERFUL ENOUGH TO TAKE ON A
PRESIDENT?
WE WILL SEE.
ONE REASON THE PERMANENT
WASHINGTON IS SO POWERFUL, SO
RESISTANT TO CHANGE OR OVERSIGHT
IS THAT IT MAKES ALLIANCES WITH
SOME OF THE LEAST IMPRESSIVE,
BUT MOST VICIOUS MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
DAYS AGO ADAM SCHIFF CLAIMED HIS
OFFICE HAD NO CONTACT WHATSOEVER
WITH THE CI WHISTLE-BLOWER.
>> FIRST OFF, HAVE YOU HEARD
FROM THE WHISTLE-BLOWER?
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER?
>> WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN DIRECTLY
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE WOULD LIKE TO.
>> Tucker: HE ALSO CLAIMED TO
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT WHAT WAS IN
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S COMPLAINT
BEFORE IT CAME OUT, BUT
YESTERDAY "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REVEALED THAT BOTH OF THOSE
CLAIMS WERE ALLIED.
HE APOLOGIZED AND AWAY SAYING
THAT HE "SHOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH
MORE CLEAR."
RIGHT.
HE NOW ADMITS HIS OFFICE SPOKE
TO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO BY THE